since I'm sitting here holding your hand
right now without having married you
first
what do the Dauntless teach about that I
say not in guide hands we are turning up
right now teach you listening to the
legion it's a third a divergent book I'm
trying to finish it because I started
it's like last year thirty yet you're
gonna realize you're like snapchatting
and not even listening so that's alright
we're about to turn up at the made in
America festival so we're going there
right now and what better way to turn up
and listen to an audiobook I mean we've
been spending so much time in the car
like you're gonna be done with this book
and I couldn't we please go okay but we
had to go to Starbucks first obviously
hmm
guys I need another audio book to listen
to as soon as this one is done and if
you guys want to go and get your own
free book you can use my audible promo
code wonderful accomplished I just seen
both hands on the wheel both 10 and 2
though he just got in and the guy was
checking my bag and he goes what's that
I go dude it's a selfie stick
it's not a weapon
you look great who are you wearing
q you wearing American you okay I won't
tell it's okay if I get down it looks I
how are you look at you hey let's see it
oh you oh my gosh even the backpack I
may have seen a nip as well Oh
so I don't know we're gonna do now but
you'll see it in the next
anyways
how far away wonder what it looks like
oh my god
Oh oh my god I'm really excited so we
just got back home from the festival and
I checked my mail Jen do you know what's
in here in this package
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
is it rude Legos yeah yeah you didn't
tell me that though I didn't tell you
Lego let's just start the opening
process and you think about it I hope it
fits because it's little boys Lego pants
it's perfect it'll fit perfect it's like
a little boys here Emmett holy crap it
looks great with your app and like the
bank the internet I like to thank
everyone you look great
look so so hey I get to see you tomorrow
face